hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round one of the
Fisher and the world championship
semi-finals it's Hikaru Nakamura versus
we've seen what happened in round one
versus uh between Magnus and uh Yani
punishi but this game it's uh I mean uh
what happens here you you will not
believe this uh so let's dive straight
into it it's the same position as in the
game Magnus Nepal and Hikaru opens the
same as in that game Ponte F4 only here
we don't have Ponte F5 Abdu Sato goes
for the immediate Pawn to G5 and okay G4
we have G captures and F4 and Rook
captures we have Pawn to H5 and Bishop
to F2 now grabbing hold of this long
diagonal we have E5 now challenging the
rook and The Rook to B for already
Hikaru finds a way to very nicely
activate his Rook uh Knight 8 to B6 and
now Knight seat to B3 we have Pawn to F5
of course the pawn cannot move uh or
rather you could move but uh it's it's a
weird move to play G captures and F5 but
the queen is now defended so you can
play it it's even the strongest move
recommended by the engine so maybe you
should even play it but okay it looks
weird so upon the H3 instead by Hikaru
we have Knight the E7 and now comes Pawn
Knight to C5 and it looks like Hikaru is
doing incredible progress here going
after the B7 Pawn uh not all that much
for abdusadrov to do but it only appears
that way this is chess 960 and here uh
the position explodes before you even
start playing the game and here Abu
santro is completely winning uh so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
what Hikaru missed while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding uh well uh
there are so many good moves for
absolute age captures and G4 is good F
characters and G4 is good but the move
that really uh shows how bad night the
D6 is is Pawn to D6 uh a knight to C5 uh
he spawn to D6 uh here there's just no
good move for Hikaru there's nothing for
you to play you can't go back if you go
back Knight to B3 then you've taken away
the B3 Square from the rook and now we
just attacked The Rook knight uh ghost
uh or even this Knight goes after the
rook and The Rook is just lost there's
no capturing it if you capture uh the
other night takes this nice place and uh
nothing to be done here even if you
don't play that even if you play
something like Knights the D3 then again
uh just Pawn to E4 and uh what do you do
you can go Knights the F4 but then H
captors and G4 or even Bishop to E5 you
can just keep harassing the knight uh
this knight uh is struggling to find
squares if e3h captures NG for each if H
captures on G4 then Bishop captures on
F4 and after e captures on F4 now again
you go for this Knight beta D5 move and
now yeah where does the root go now you
go to B3 and now Knight captures on F4
leaving
um in a in a completely winning position
if if G captures then even the bishop
comes into the game with the check so uh
he would uh well this would be
completely lost for white but the other
thing is uh even even if you don't want
to calculate all of this Knight chasing
uh even if you try to go after the B7
Pawn which was the original idea after
Knight captures on B7 there's King to C8
just attacking that Knight
now with the rook and the king so you
are threatening to pick up the Knight
give up The Rook for two pieces and now
if Knights the A5 seems like you've
gotten the night out just Queen captures
an A2 attacks the Knight and attacks the
undefended rule can be won so that's a
lot and that is exactly why both of them
missed it so does not find that he plays
Queen captures on 80 you which is also a
nice move but now Hikaru can play Rook
to C1 hikar plays King to C1 and now
Abdu satrov is again winning but again
it's such a such a disgusting position
you you have to move back the queen uh
Queen to F7 as there are threats of your
queen uh being captured here but he
doesn't move the queen he plays Knight E
to D5 goes after the rook and now Hikaru
just plays Knight 8 to B3 and now Rook
day one is coming the queen is trapped
uh and okay Abdul sattar grabs The Rook
here we have Rook the A1 and now Queen
capture Sun A1 we have Knight captures
on A1 and not want the E4 so it's a
complete mess of a position
of Donna Queen Hikaru
I had to give up uh uh both of his Rooks
for the queen uh Ken Abu sator of do
something in this game so let's check
out what happened Bishop page for check
Bishop to F6 and Hikaru very happily
trades Bishop captures with Rook
captures and now Queen to D4 uh going
after the Rook here so I ended the night
and this is the biggest problem for Abu
satra of this uh beautiful Fork so here
at night goes back defends The Rook but
now just Pawn to C4 kicks away the
defender of duruk so now of course he
can't move the Knight he plays F
captures on G4 now with the idea of Rook
to F1 so Bishop to G2 by Hikaru and now
a nice Queen side castles uh C captures
on D5 we have Rook to F5 and now H
captors and G4 we have real characters
on D5 attacks the queen queen to C3 uh
you could also play Queen captures on e4
but then Rook captures on C5 your knight
hang so you have to defend the night
Queen to C3 uh and now we have Bishop to
G6 the defending the E4 pawn and now
Knight the C2 getting that Knight into
the game you might think uh but why
don't we just eliminated this Pawn here
uh well you can do that that's that's
not a problem but Hikaru says Knight to
C2 he wants to activate pieces there's
no uh you know not a problem he doesn't
have to go after that pawn uh we have H
Captain Sanji for and now Knight
captures on e4 uh we have Bishop
captures on e4 Bishop captures and The
Rook to G5 now another big puts his Rook
behind the pass pawn and Bishop to G2
it's important uh prevent this Pawn from
ever reaching G2 we have Pawn to G3 and
now Pawn to B4 uh we have C6 now uh and
pawn to B5 hikar wants to trade as many
pieces in front of the black king as
possible he does have a queen queen
covers a lot of squares so we want to
open up your opponent's king and this
also means giving up at the pawn but
then you get to capture the G3 Pawn so
Rook captures on B5 Queen captures on G3
and now Rook the f8 so it's still uh two
Rooks in the night for a queen uh Knight
and Bishop of course Hikaru is up
material but the white king is uh wide
in the open so maybe Abdul satrov can
use this so Knights the E3 Rook the C5
check with King to D1 and now Knight the
C4 offering a trade of Knight which
Hikaru very happily accepts captors
captures and now Bishop to H3 putting
the bishop on this long diagonal uh we
have Rook seat to F4 and now Queen to D3
threatening to pick up the D7 Pawn so
Rook 8 to F7 defending the pawn and now
Queen to D6 and now how do you continue
this game uh well you have to be very
very careful you have to prevent any
tracks any any captures and you don't
want to disconnect your Rooks but if you
wanna try something you have to do one
of those things so here Rook to H4 goes
after the bishop now Queen to G3 we have
Rook H back to H7 the Rooks are now
safely defending each other and pawn to
D4 now Hikaru has to find some play
they're using the the two pawns that he
has Rook H to G7 goes after the queen
queen E5 we've rooked the E7 and now
Queen to D6 we have Rook e to F7 King to
D2 and now Rook to H7 goes after the
bishop Bishop G4 Rook H to G7 so abusato
will try anything and it's up to Hikaru
to prove that he can win this bishop H5
goes after The Rook Rook F5 and now
Bishop to G6 uh we have rooked F1 and
now Pawn to E4
we have pawned A5 uh another bag starts
pushing his past pawn and now Bishop to
F5 and now uh What uh Hikaru did with
this D4 e for Bishop F5 setup is that he
says that okay if you ever go for some
Rook to G2 check I can play King E3 and
now if you ever want to check me again I
can always put my king on F6 and you are
never touching my king there with the
spawn on e4 bishop and F5 setup so first
he made sure that nothing can happen to
him and now it's uh he's he's the one
who's attacking basically or your Pawn
here would be hanging uh it's a it's a
terrible position so Rook to F7 instead
you have to keep an eye on this pawn
queen to E5 and now King the d8 uh we
have Queen captures on A5 with check
King the E7 and now Queen to E5 with
check King to d8 and now Queen A5 check
oh sorry we repeat a few times King is
seven Queen to E5 check uh but not right
away first King Day 2 attacks The Rook
Rook to G1 and only now Queen the E5
check King 28 and now Queen to B8 check
in the B7 Pawn as well so King is seven
Queen captures on B7 we have King to f8
and now Queen to B8 with check King G7
Queen E5 check with King to f8 and now
Queen to D6 King G7 and now only now
Bishop captures and D7 so you have to
make sure that nothing works and now you
just gobble up the third Pawn so it
seems like after we'll be able to do
something with those spawns but no he
just allows the car to gobble them up to
gobble them up as the there was no way
to save them so Rook after F1 your last
attempt at saving this game is by trying
to check the white king to Infinity
Queen E7 check with King to H6 now comes
Bishop to F5
uh rookie one check with King 32 Rook
the D1 Chuck King the E3 and he was in
this position on move 59 that another
make up the sattro resigned to the game
and Hikaru wins the first game of their
match and uh I've just learned that he
also won the second game of their match
so Hikaru is now leading 2-0 and it will
be very interesting to see if another
back will be able to bounce back it's
not not a pleasant place to be in uh
because now like we said uh whatever you
try you can always hide your King on F6
for example rookie to F1 check you go
here and now after King The Well Queen
H7 is also very annoying but there's no
good way to stop this if you play King
H5 you just go after the king a queen to
H7 tracking G5 now you can deliver a
check here now King H4 check here King
G3 Queen E3 check and now uh nothing
worse here if you go here you just get
the checkmated if you go here then
Bishop to H3 check wins material and if
you go up the board then King F6 takes
away the G5 Square from the King and now
again uh Quinta H3 will be checked maybe
if you play Rook to H1 then Queen to G5
will be Checkmate too many checkmates
here you just have to resign uh so yeah
basically uh that's why Hikaru did it uh
Saturn did it right away uh he knows
this is what's coming so the best to
resign and then save your energy for for
the next game which he also lost so
incredible stuff by Hikaru uh he's very
very close to reaching the finals where
he will face either Magnus or ianishi uh
but uh let me just check because they
were still playing when I started
recording this video
uh Magnus was also having a beautiful
position in the second game but he
blundered terribly and then Jan just won
the game so yeah equalizes whereas
Hikaru has a two to zero lead so
incredible stuff
um uh a very nice turn of events we'll
see what happens further on in the event
uh good stuff so far uh so that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it really
incredible that Abdul satro was winning
on move eight after Knight to C5 just D6
imagine you're playing a Hikaru and on
move eight you have a move like D6 just
to win the game completely but as you've
seen it's incredibly complicated it
would take too much time to calculate
um and you don't have that much time to
spare uh so yeah once again hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Johanna Nathan helsley Jacoby more chess
960 and goncalo morovo for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
fine event until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day